as don's week at the warehouse was
wrapping up it was time to come clean
with his employees actually everybody
uh
got an announcement to me don't nobody
want to hear your bull newbie okay don't
nobody want to hear it i think you will
care about this one so uh gather around
i'm not actually a new employee you can
say that again you a waste of space as
far as i'm concerned can't get another
done in time like like a snail over here
[Laughter]
i am
actually
president of the company
you're on undercover boss
tv show yeah what
in this week
since i've been working here amongst you
i uh
got to hear each and every one of your
stories
it's just about and uh
you know i was just playing right you
know
i was just trying to lighten the mood in
the workplace and whatnot okay thank you
joseph
bill
buddy
you're telling me that your car broke
down and it hasn't been working right
ever since well i want to get you a new
ford explorer
oh my god thank you so much mark that
means
so much to me my whole family died in
one day
thank you huge car crash huge man we
were having a family picnic and then
this truck just came on through and just
killed everybody it chopped everybody's
heads off illinois
you were worried that you were not going
to be able to afford college for your
two two boys and uh i'm starting a
college fund for them both putting ten
thousand dollars in each one of them
this is amazing
i'm so grateful i i can't make no family
anymore because my dick got chopped up
in the accident and now i pee out the
side sometimes i wake up at the middle
of night i just i start to pee
let's go right in my mouth
sometimes poop come out the other side i
don't even know what
dick is in eight pieces okay you know he
just give me a raise i ain't asking for
no kind of scholarship joseph i'm gonna
get i'm gonna go and get to you right
okay dude i mentioned i was a prostitute
since the age of 17 15 joseph 10 joseph
seven children three childhoods since i
was three i was in i was a prostitute in
the womb i do put his pp in my mama and
they got inside of me and then
they gave me money joseph's please man
you have been rude to me
since the moment i came here
come on man i mean i was playing with
you i knew you was the boss the whole
time man look at this fake ass mustache
ow that's my real mustache joseph it
really hurt
you're fired
get out of here i can't understand what
get out of here
i got a i got a rare condition that make
me unlikable don't you don't joseph
pants
lance you've been in the urinal with me
you see me in the urinal i'm sorry but
do not engage tell them
pieces joseph leave lancelot it's true
so then give me a little bit of money no
it's not gonna happen can i have a
joseph
he did joseph leave norman out of this
who's norman the foreman norman the
foreman that's his name
i know that
i work intimately with him no you don't
you're fired all right
all right you're out the door with you
joseph i am sorry about that ah
is he gone
okay uh
betty
when you told me
that your father passed away it hit me
because my father passed away but my
dick got chopped up dough joseph my dick
got chopped that is so disrespectful
joseph what are you doing i thought you
left joseph like gristle off a
thanksgiving turkey you're lying and i
got a crystal dick joseph that's wildly
inappropriate straight meat gristle just
hanging out here right here right now
you can't see that's it
coming up you know you have so many
siblings and just to know
that we both share
a familial bond and that there's nothing
that can take that away but my dick got
chopped up joseph
how did you
okay all right
good morning tom
jason
how you doing there dave crystal
tommy
good morning jake
how are you
pretty good kenny yeah yeah
uh you know so early in the morning i'm
sorry to be very bad news but uh you
know how i was supposed to work late
tonight
well i got to run this errand for mr
mahina and he says that you're going to
have to cover for me so there it is i
don't need i'm sorry drop the ax
okay so
again yeah
oh you know what just remembered
mr mahina also
almost slipped my mind wants us to uh
change parking spaces
what yeah me personally i enjoy the
nine-minute walk but uh he said that we
have to do it believe it i hate it as
much as you do what are you gonna do
there's nothing you can do mr mahina
said it mahina
this whole situation has been
mahinoonized it just seems a little
confusing to me
as to why mr mahina
would give a [ __ ] where we park
how's that i mean why would he care
where we are i i don't know the answer
to that question i i mean that's just
what he said hey the mahina works in
mysterious ways you know what i'm gonna
ask him myself cause no that's okay i'll
do it
uh mr mahina sir i know you're busy but
can i speak to you about the parking
switch
what is there to talk about kenny i told
you and jade to switch parking spaces
don't you know who i am i am mr mojito
and i'm a real real person in here
now you
that it was crazy in there i mean that
was
tense yeah
you know what's really crazy though
i've been working here for about a year
and i've never even seen mr mojina well
see that's that's an easy one to answer
that's because he comes in before you
come into work and he's still working
when you leave that's what makes it mr
mohina you know come on we're talking
about mr mohina here right
it makes perfect sense you know i bet
the hard-working boss would love to meet
a hard-working employee you know shares
the same values so i'm going to go ahead
and just introduce myself no no uh wait
you can't go into mr mohini's room are
you crazy no one except me is allowed to
go in there mr mahina is busy
okay fine you made your point clear man
thank you very much jake i think it's
what
come on man
what
question my existence
i'll have that end of the year report to
you by 10.
[Music]
okay you know what it wasn't my fault
all right
i i i had the money like you said in a
trash bag in the back of my car and i
was gonna go straight to the drop spot
all right
[Music]
no no oh okay okay okay okay no hey hey
hey hey man ain't no need for you to get
comfortable okay because because i'm
telling you man what happened wasn't my
fault all right i i i i i i i i i drove
to the agreed upon location man
oh come in
come on
okay okay okay
okay
okay because there's no need to have
anything crazy in a paper bag i'm
telling you there's an explanation for
what went down
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay let's calm down
now
let's calm down man there ain't no need
oh not a juice box
ain't no need to eat a meal and then do
some crazy
with a sandwich container and a juice
box
oh man come on
come on man
just chill out a little bit just do you
need to relax man you need to take it
easy and relax oh
oh god damn now come on man don't do it
don't do it don't don't man come on man
oh
okay look it's getting crazy now it's
gonna stop it's gotta stop right now
okay you cleaning yourself up before you
do some ill come on man what you doing
what you want to know well i'll tell you
whatever you want to know man just
please stop this cold ass man i'm
thinking you dog please oh
no no okay let's okay maybe it was my
fault a little bit maybe it's my fault a
little bit but don't just what you want
to do with that juice box man we're
going to do it we're going to do a straw
what are you going to do with the straw
come on man listen listen no no no i did
it i did i did it okay i did it i did i
left the car i left for three minutes so
please don't do anything with the straw
why aren't you stopping
fine
okay man ha ha i beat you to it okay
i got your point all right man
huh
oh
man that's a [ __ ]
[Music]
will we be having more problems out of
him sir
no
yeah
that's what i'm talking about
i'd love a cupcake
thank you so much for coming today uh as
you know every year the vice president
hosts the annual company luncheon
uh so i brought you here to make sure
that none of my material could be in any
way misconstrued as sexist or racist or
homophobic so if you hear anything that
could be in any way offensive to anyone
just raise your hand and
oh i haven't really started yet
did you find something offensive the
fact that you think i need a man's
permission to raise my hand is insane i
can raise my hand whenever i want to
raise my hand because i'm a free woman
so i should just raise my hand like this
like a big old black power fist yeah huh
boss man is that what you want from me
is this what you wanted a floppy gay
hand just floating around in the air
well here you go here's my floppy gay
hand at the end of my limp gay wrist
happy no jesus no
wow what why not mary marino or rachel
no or bathsheba no why does it have to
be jesus a man and are we talking about
the jesus that accepts everyone or the
jesus who doesn't believe that people
should be able to love who they love oh
maybe i should just break out in some
gospel songs screaming and hollering and
hooting oh lordy lordy no this isn't the
speech yet can i just do the speech oh
you want this [ __ ] to shut up is that
it what's the matter the black guys
making way too much noise in your movie
theater forgive me for lisping and
lilting through your speech no i just
meant
mess with the hands man i ain't gonna
shoot you where are you gonna grab my
breath now protect yourself from the gay
invasion guys oh guys should i leave
sorry men and women let's exclude
everybody who identifies themselves as
something else because they're not
people i meant people who's people my
people do i speak for my people all
right more like all white more like no
rights more like women are second-class
citizens
right okay stop
men women people of all ethnicities
genders
sexual orientation religion can i please
just get to my speech
fine
yeah
okay here goes
a [ __ ] a pole lock and an arab walk
into a bar i love arab jokes
bring it on you had me at pollock
welcome to the team mr wise
thank you now being an arizona assistant
state's attorney is an important job one
we take very seriously in fact
we are willing to do anything to win
it's my honor sir and i look forward to
serving the state of arizona are these
marbles how's that
it's just admiring your container of
marbles
why yes
my wife got them for me as a gift
for my birthday
which brings me to a speech
i'd like to give anyone on their first
day here at the state's attorney office
of arizona
you see
lady justice is a committed woman she's
a slippery little scalar as you can
observe
[Music]
doesn't clean
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is going on
what what are you doing
oh ah
marbles they're just i i gotta tell you
they're just so beautiful that i was
wondering what it would feel like to in
my mouth like what would the marbles
feel like if they were in my mouth
that's
you know
what
just you know
you know like just what would it feel
like if they were just kind of a whole
ton of marbles in my in my face
well don't do that
just
just don't do that yeah yeah of course
of course
why why what am i doing over here i mean
that's that's the thing that a child
would do you know
you were saying
i was saying that lady justice
just stands there in my office
looking at me
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
forget the marbles boy
spit the marbles out please
there you go
well
all right
how many
really
do you have any
i'm gonna wait for the last
i'm assuming this
i know there's another one in there
nope all right
i am i'm
they're just so beautiful i can't it's
these marbles i got to tell you you
obviously don't take this job there
seriously i do sir it's just these
particular marbles i just needed to feel
what they felt like in my mouth i don't
know what is wrong with me you know we
do serious business here right yes i do
know that i'm a hundred percent aware of
that yeah cause i've forgotten where i
was you were saying that justice is a
dumb blind old lady i heard everything
yes no she's not
dumb
but she is blind
she's reminiscent of
kerry washington
[Music]
good job
[Applause]
so
[Music]
janice
send in the cleanup crew
another one fell for the marble trick
[Music]
oh
[Music]